happy hats day to you happy hats day
dear
Timothy weed ology doesn't like clown
happy hats day to you that's me
read ever since I was a kid I never
really fit in no one understands me nice
cat lady
this used to be a recurring issue angle
how thing I have an anger issue I think
you got an anger issue are you aware
that that robe that you're wearing isn't
fooling anybody from the world of the
pig these pigs are mysterious and weird
am i right I don't trust them I think
they're up to something
your opinion is not me that went well
give your me
set sail for piggy island you tried to
tell us but we didn't listen what do we
do now that is where they went
and so that is where we're going we're
gonna get those eggs back come on we're
bird we're descended from dinosaurs
we're not supposed to be nice
Oh
yeah point made time to get angry Wow
about that
she's been shoot fireballs out of her
butt
he's coming back did we win
can we get an ice pack for house
Chuck is that you this is the house
in every civilized community there's an
outcast from a young age the outcast has
trouble fitting in can sometimes feel
invisible now thank you
and often has difficulty finding a mate
but despite all the outcasts still
searches for a connection
the world of the pig oh my god
what's peak please request the honor of
your friendship how you doing welcome to
our new frailes there's something going
on here these pigs mysterious little
weird am i right
that part about them I really admire I
don't trust your opinion is not me the
doctor yes we have a burn victim here
what do we do now you're asking me you
tried to tell us but we didn't listen
we're gonna get those eggs back come on
we're birds birds descended from
dinosaurs we're not supposed to be nice
oh yeah point made rest in peace by
first
drop your nuts to move your butt it's
time to get angry
she can shoot fireballs out of her butt
guards there is a real bird in these
[ __ ] bring him to me
not in these walls in the castle come on
you guys
why do birds suddenly appear every time
you are near me hey rat how are you oh
I'm horrible
we're gonna be working on managing our
anger through movement Eagle Heron
teacup warrior
rabbit okay pigeon and of course
downward duck
sometimes when I get upset I have been
known to blow up excuse me
party foul unbelievable
Oh wherever going
we practice this a hundred times give it
to me we're gonna come in again
this new year
when everyone around the world is busy
making resolutions we all know aren't
going to last make a promise you know
you can keep to just be yourself
nice chat with you the Angry Birds movie
wishing you a Happy New Year in theaters
this May in 3d and RealD 3d
yes
hey red how are you oh I'm horrible mr.
riah this needs to be a recurring issue
am i a passionate bird yes
but why does it matter that we're not
the same
Bobby the anger might be contagious
he started it I'm a pig
what's a pig show them how we doing how
you doing what I think it is scuse me
those are fragile right not yours you
won't make it I will get see Oh welcome
and you're not asking basic questions
well this just got awkward doesn't
anyone see what's going on here the
whole world is in danger anyone knows
what these pigs are up to
it's Mighty Eagle out of there don't
swallow it
it's him
horrible turn of events horrible
won't mr. Rick yes seems to be a
recurring issue am i a passionate bird